leute leute leute da macht man mal eben
sechs wochen urlaub kommt zurück und
lebt in einer ökodiktatur
in deutschland tobt plötzlich ein
kulturkampf gegen das auto alle hatten
drauf rum ich frage wer schützt unsere
autos ja tempolimit tempolimit fordert
eine kommission des verkehrsministeriums
dem klimaschutz aber zum glück haben wir
ja an die scheuer
wer direkt gesagt tempolimit ist quatsch
und verstößt zitat gegen jeden
menschenverstand irgendwie möglich wird
er das sagt ja verstößt gegen
menschenverstand alle anderen
zivilisierten länder haben ein
tempolimit aber die sind halt verrückt
und sie hat wieder zugeschlagen die ente
des tages die ende des tages hier
übrigens links im bild meine damen und
herren
der rechte wäre wahrscheinlich der
bessere verkehrsminister an die steuer
ab jetzt offiziell der schutzheilige der
deutschen bleifüße ja ganz eindeutig ja
ich meine ist es ist ja fakt du kannst
uns deutschen alles nehmen
stolz 6d nennt sie ganz egal aber nicht
das recht auf rasen
dafür kommt schließlich touristen aus
aller welt wir können gute rotenbühl
fahren ja besser als in holland ja wir
besser für wäsche ja ja
[Applaus]
muss sparen
ja ich verstehe was er meint durch
nordrhein westfalen will man so schnell
wie möglich durch fahren
es geht mir auch sowohl ich hier wohne
aber ist das die lösung
ist das die lösung laut gewerkschaft der
polizei ist die konservativere der
beiden polizeigewerkschaften ist
geschwindigkeit immer noch der killer
nummer eins auf unseren straßen
fakt aber gut dass wir die debatte
endlich mal ehrlich führen die debatte
hatten wir ja noch nie nach der heutigen
kabinettssitzung sagte
regierungssprecher ost die
bundesregierung sich für ein generelles
tempolimit keinen anlass ja damals war
claus kleber noch echt sexy ja keine
ahnung was seitdem passiert ist der
tempolimits streit ist ein echter
evergreen man kann es fast nicht mehr
hören
wie wärs denn mal mit einem kompromiss
höchstgeschwindigkeit 150 oder ja keine
ahnung 210 bei nässe kann man alles
vorschlagen keine chance keine chance
jedes tempolimit bedroht die freiheit
das ist ja dieser neue freiheitsbegriff
das recht des deutschen kleinere autos
von der linken spur zu kühlen wenn du
sowas in frage stellt gibt es direkt
ärger mit der ganzen bande adac bild csu
ein generelles tempolimit würde weder
zur verkehrssicherheit beitragen noch
würde es wesentlich zum umweltschutz
beitragen auf 6 traffic ausgebauten
autobahnen mit quasi null verkehr mit
einschläfernden 120 oder 130 zu fahren
das kann auch in gefahr
brandgefährlich brandgefährlich dann
dann lieber mit 2/100 über die bahnen
ramsauer ja wahrscheinlich ist es so
tempolimit und deutsche das geht nicht
zusammen muss man auch ehrlich sein
dafür sind wir schlicht nicht gebaut der
deutsche autofahrer der beste autofahrer
der welt
neueste forschungen belegen dass
deutsche gehirn ist für niedrige
geschwindigkeiten leider gar nicht
ausgelegt unter 50 km h gerät der fahrer
schlagartig in einer tiefschlafphase
zwischen 50 und 80 kocht er sich kaffee
und telefoniert ab tempo 120 reinigt der
deutsche gern den innenraum des
fahrzeugs erst oberhalb von 130 schaut
er auch mal auf die straße sondern wird
aktiv augen und ohren arbeiten normal
und jenseits von 2 und sachen werden
endlich auch seine geschlechtsorgane
voll durchblutet und der autofahrer kann
sich fortpflanzen
also könnte er wenn er seine frau nicht
neulich überfahren hätte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind nicht das nur noch
wahnsinn der krieg gegen das auto zum
glück zum glück hat der deutsche
autofahrer noch ein paar letzte freunde
in diesem land zb dem jungen arzt
professor dieter köhler ja jetzt
zusammen mit seinen kollegen endlich die
grenzwert lüge entlarvt jaja als
praktischer weise kurz vor all den
fahrverboten stellt sich doch raus
stickoxide und feinstaub sind überhaupt
nicht ungesund und er seine art ja
wellness gas der lungenexperte ist einer
von mehr als 100 wissenschaftlern die
bezweifeln dass feinstaub und stickoxide
in deutschen städten
gesundheitsgefährdend sein denn es gibt
keinen einzigen toten dadurch in
deutschland auch nicht in europa ja
klingt plausibel sich das gehört habe
habe ich direkt meinen sommerurlaub am
stuttgarter neckartor gebucht ja das
wird super
übrigens hat kein seriöser
wissenschaftler jemals behauptet
stickoxide und feinstaub würden allein
todesfälle verursachen
das sind brandbeschleuniger im körper
die entzündungen und erkrankungen bis
hin zu krebs auslösen können und zwar
vor allem bei menschen mit
vorerkrankungen oder bei kindern wissen
die auf die auf auspuff höhe leben
deutschen dackel war ganz zu schweigen
zweiter ist
und schon kann man vielleicht mit
deutschen banken natürlich das muss man
zugeben hat auch nie einer bestritten
werden diese grenzwerte auch politisch
festgelegt das ist immer eine abwägung
zwischen dem schutz von risikogruppen
und der mobilität der bürger an die
scheuer die ente des tages wetter
trotzdem begeistert gegen grenzwerte
warum
weil's so schön ablenkt vom eigenen
versagen
wer hat er den leuten jahrelang
angeblich sauberen diesel auf gequatscht
und beim beschiss der autoindustrie
weggeguckt es folgt ein mega wird zum
thema autobauer
die stellen sie doch bloß die führen sie
doch am nasenring durch die arena oder
weiß ich vergebe mit ihnen stimmen haben
natürlich dass es auch mega ansagen von
mir bekommen
absolut absolut mega ansagen hier die
top 3 der mega show ansagen an die
deutsche autoindustrie auf 3 macht immer
genau so weiter dann wann kommt endlich
mein neuer q7
und auf einfach genau
man sagt
übrigens ist die debatte über die genaue
höhe der grenzwert oder den standort der
messgeräte absolut legitim aber mal eben
die wissenschaft an sich inklusive
70.000 internationale studien zu
luftschadstoffen diskreditieren nun sich
bei bild und co einzuschleimen ist
irgendwie unwürdig herr minister aber
klar
viele deutsche sind jetzt verwirrt
welchen wissenschaftlern soll man
glauben in münchen hat gerade ein neues
forschungslabor eröffnet geleitet von dr
albrecht humboldt de erholt was genau
forschen sie da recke schön dass sie
fragen wir vom an die scheuer institut
für gesunden menschenverstand versuchen
etwas völlig neues und zwar wissenschaft
auf basis von fakten
das ist noch nie versucht worden ein
beispiel dieses kaninchen atmet seit
zwei wochen ununterbrochen stickoxide
putzmunter und dieses kaninchen haben
wir zwei stunden in rotwein geschmort
und jetzt frage ich sie
welches kaninchen sieht besser aus sagen
sie mal sind sie überhaupt
wissenschaftler
ja klar ich habe einen kittel an die
sogenannte mainstream wissenschaft
behauptet stickoxide seien schädlich 112
lungenärzte sagen quatsch und das ist
noch nicht alles
472 augenärzte sagen unter eid dass sie
stickoxid noch nie gesehen haben und
über 100 euro logan mit porsche sind
sich sicher dass sie keinen kleinen
penis abend interessant aber die
grenzwerte schützen noch bestimmte
risikogruppen in städten mit zu
schlechter luft entschuldigung wenn
ältere menschen oder chronisch kranke
probleme mit schlechter luft haben dann
ist das ja auch ein stück weit
evolutionär so gewollt
er wirke es müssen endlich wieder fakten
in die debatte und tempolimit wollen sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht nein bringt
nichts hier crashtest ein suv brettert
mit 180 sachen in einen kleinwagen im
suv bleiben alle unverletzt
die im kleinwagen haben ein problem
warum weil sie zu langsam waren zu wenig
tempo ist der killer
wissen sie wie viele unfallopfer
fahrradfahrer sind wir haben hier
ausgerechnet würden alle fahrräder
mindestens 80 km h fahren dann werden
die leute schon zu hause bevor der
unfall passiert nein das sagt sich immer
so leicht irgendwas ist gefährlich oder
ungesund ohne beweise ist erstmal alles
gesund hier unser proband ballert sich
mit einer nagel pistole nägel in die
hand tut weh klar aber liegt es auch
wirklich am nagel
vielleicht hat der mann eine
vorerkrankung wir wissen es nicht uns
viele langfristige studien noch mal ja
die zeit haben wir leider nicht albrecht
hat meine damen und herren vielen dank
[Applaus]
tempolimit interessanterweise haben sich
in umfragen mehr männer dabei deutlich
mehr männer als frauen gegen das
tempolimit ausgesprochen und das passt
zur diskussion über sogenannte toxische
männlichkeit die gerade in den deutschen
feuilletons geführt wird
eine unverschämtheit als wäre der mann
an sich schon eine krankheit als wäre
der männlichen chromosomensatz 1 1 ein
gesellschaftliches problem das kann doch
alles nicht mehr wahr sein freundin aber
den kollegen dietmar wischmeyer erreicht
das jetzt toxische männlichkeit deswegen
hat er sogar eine eigene zeitschrift
herausgebracht jetzt am kiosk die neue
dietmar die zeitschrift für den
enttäuschten älteren mann
hallo maria
es reicht rauchen ist überall verboten
tagsüber muss man nüchtern sein und
jetzt auch noch ein tempolimit sollen
wir uns gleich die eier abschneiden oder
reicht vorerst noch die leinenpflicht
für den mann sein auto sagt er ich kann
250 was kannst du dann darfst du doch
nicht den schwanz einziehen
nur wenn du dem tod auch dem der anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer in die augen schaust
fühlst du das leben in dir ist das so
schwer zu verstehen
ein mann hat ein ziel im leben das
erreicht man nicht indem er sich
minutenlang den arsch von dem nissan
micra vor man guckt wenn ich dann noch
lese dass nicht nur mein v8 dem planeten
vernichtet sondern auch mein team und
steht dann kommt sich wirklich weißt du
überhaupt wie viel rucola ich fressen
müsste um den mehrwert eines 500 gramm
steaks zu erreichen viereinhalb kilo
das schafft nicht mal eine ziege an
einem tag und ich habe auch einfach
nicht die zeit
der mann braucht fleisch sonst läuft er
nur auf drei zylindern und konnte im job
von jedem x-beliebigen mädchen ersetzt
werden
aber auch männer haben weiche seiten
jeder würde für eine neue hält die seine
frau verlassen ist als etwa falsch wir
trinken ständig alkohol sterben fünf
jahre früher als frauen und hängen uns
doppelt so oft auf weil wir so sensibel
sind
wenn ein mann kennt keine probleme' salt
solutions baby und es ist mein
verdammtes recht mir jedes silvester mit
einem polenböller einen weiteren finger
weg zu sprengen wenn eine frau nämlich
noch stundenlang nachdenkt weiß ein mann
schon dass er gerade falsch gehandelt
hat ich sage immer erst wenn der letzte
kubicki verschwunden ist werdet ihr
merken dass man mit robert habeck nicht
anständig saufen kann
[Applaus]
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen die ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt dass selbst ein beschissenes
autobahn
[Musik]